big and rich have plenty of big hits but
did you know big kenny has a big love
for cars and he is sharing his passion
in his new show big kenny crank it up
garage which you can see on the circle
network and look who it is it's big
kenny right now what's going on buddy
crank it up crank it up how you doing
man great man so is this is this a build
show are you just going around you're
showcasing some awesome builds
we are showcasing awesome builds our
motto is if it rides glides float
supplies and moves otherwise it sounds
like something we want to see wheels
wings jets of slides
i love it i'm excited about traveling
around the country and finding some of
the coolest baddest rides there are and
uh really you know our goal is to shut
down a lot
on these creators you know these these
these tradesmen these craftsmen these
super talented individuals who made some
of the most awesome rides in the usa and
season two is upon us we have a couple
of vegas episodes i'm really excited
about season two because you're hitting
one of my favorites danny coker counting
cars you're gonna check out danny what
are you and danny doing on this season
well uh we got to got to meet danny
for you know counts customs danny's just
an absolutely fantastic human being and
super super talented and he took us for
a ride in his 1932
ford uh five window high top and uh
man what a what a beautiful beautiful
car it is and how awesome it is to to
just see all the creations that he's
made there
at his museum you know i love that he he
took a ford uh chassis and put a chevy
engine in it so you know he's not afraid
to just slam
whatever is the best thing to make the
best builds together
and if you get a chance to go there and
see his museum
oh man his the collection of works he's
got from years and years it's just it's
just absolutely amazing and his show is
coming up on his episodes on july 14th
uh so you want to make sure to turn into
uh circle tv on july 14th to see danny
coker man in this this 1932 four it's
bad long well i love danny i love you
it's gonna be a great combination do you
have a do you have a preference cars or
music you gotta choose one which do you
go with
music
music i gotta choose music because
that's what i do you know you know i
love vehicles i love cars i love things
that just ride you know i'm a motorcycle
guy
i've just enjoyed you know messing
around with building stuff my whole life
i was a farm boy raised up on a farm so
you know we just had to take whatever we
get our hands on and put it together and
make it work and
you know i'm just so inspired by
meeting these folks you know across the
country that are you know have the
capabilities not only just make it work
but to make it beautiful man i mean to
put the shine on it and and have you
know high craftsmanship like you could
just never imagine
it's just super inspirational for me to
to you know have an opportunity to spend
time with these folks it's the kind of
thing that i would do you know whether i
was making a show or not it's just
just just awesome the car community is
really cool and you said the right
answer because you need the music you
need the money from the music to buy
some really cool cars big kenny thank
you so much for joining us we're gonna
check out the show on the circle network
and we'll check out that danny coker
special in july thanks buddy we
appreciate it have a great weekend